right before we started i just saw this
video on twitter and i just have to
share it with you this is rashida talib
you know this woman she is a member of
the squad she is a marxist she's an
anti-american activist i don't know how
she's in congress really just a truly
truly horrible woman
but every now and again they get to be
fully exposed
on camera they forget that there's
cameras around them at all times and
listen to what she says
about masks this is just in the last
hour
[Music]
uh
did you catch that there at the end as
she took off her mask to talk to the
person showing you that it's all theater
i'm only wearing this because there's a
republican tracker there
man she is an
extraordinary liar and i get it they lie
to us about
absolutely everything but think about
how perverse what she's doing there is
so i'm wearing a mess because there's a
republican there so i know masks are
nonsense i wear it to fool
my idiot progressive base who just likes
masks or they're afraid of everything or
we're just trying to manipulate them and
keep everybody in constant paralysis and
thinking that they're going to die and
everything else i'm only doing this
because of those mean republicans
you know meaning i'm i know the masks
are nonsense i'm only doing it because
there's a republican there these people
are absolutely evil at what point is
this not evil it's not enough to just
say oh they're well intended and the
retailers made with good intentions or
they're nice people and they're just
confused or the science isn't settled no
she's evil she's evil actually she's
evil she's an evil c word there i know
if i say the c word i'm not you know
what i'm gonna write it down
i'm going to write it down because if i
say the c word we're going to get
demonetized and crushed in the algorithm
am i right yeah so i just wrote down the
c word
you know what i'm going to show it to
you i'm going to show it to you too
because i'm pretty sure we won't get
demonetized if i didn't say it but i
come on
cat okay
she's an evil cat
because everybody hates cats they're
sitting there they're staring at you
they're gonna pounce on you scratch you
in the eye
you know cats are so evil that if you
they don't want pregnant women to touch
kitty litter did you know that that's an
actual thing and they say that somehow
if you live in a house or a small
apartment this was a big thing in new
york city years ago you live in a small
apartment with a cat with a kitty litter
the kitty litter releases something the
cat poop and the kitty litter actually
releases something that can make women
go insane that's an actual thing google
it that's a real thing anyway she's a
lying c word
awful what an awful human being she
knows the mask is [ __ ] they know
it's [ __ ] she's standing outside
there's unmasked people there masked
people and then she pulls it down to
tell either the reporter or whoever that
was
that that this is all nonsense i only do
it for theater so the republicans aren't
mean to me
god awful like when are we just enough
americans just going to say enough is
enough we are being governed by a bunch
of absolutely horrific people and get
some balls people and start standing up
against this abject nonsense actually
speaking of that i wish i could have
gone this morning but there was a huge
anti-vaxx mandate rally in beverly hills
uh right by where the old trump rallies
were that i went to which and there were
tons of people out there and you're not
going to believe it they were out there
and it's 80 degrees and sunny and there
were american flags and they were
talking about freedom and the
constitution and good stuff like that
we're going to go to the next one i
obviously couldn't do it if i'm here
with you guys right now but these people
are evil so i just want to be very very
clear rashida talib you are an evil c
word